et notre président de la commission
d'investitures ça c'est pour faire
trembler eric ya la parole pour dix
minutes
[Applaudissements]
mais chez un ami mes chers amis
merci à tous d'être rassemblés ici à
menton merci à son maire jean claude
guibal
merci à notre président du conseil
national nouveau président délégué de
notre famille politique
mon ami jean leonetti qui a animé ces
travaux avec ses convictions avec son
esprit d'unité de rassemblement que
j'apprécie tant dans le département des
alpes-maritimes en travaillant avec lui
et avec tous les élus tous les
parlementaires de notre famille
politique avec les conseillers
départementaux et notre président du
département charles ange ginésy merci
tout particulièrement un autre président
à laurent wauquiez d'avoir choisi menton
d'avoir choisi notre fédération d'avoir
choisi les alpes maritimes pour
organiser ce conseil national tellement
important un conseil national qui
constitue une brique de plus dans la
reconstruction de cette maison de cette
force de cette famille merci à laurent
nous avons avec laurent wauquiez un chef
nous avons un cap nous avons désormais
un projet et nous lui faisons confiance
et puis merci à vous merci à vous vous
qui êtes les militants les militants des
républicains bien sûr mais d'abord et
surtout les militants de la france merci
à vous qui n'avez jamais douté
merci à vous qui avez été loyaux qui
avait été droit dans la tempête
dans les moments difficiles vous avez
été là vous êtes là et vous serez
toujours là parce que vous êtes notre
famille sans vous sans vous nous ne
serions rien vous êtes d'autres chemins
vous êtes notre espérance
alors oui mes amis souvenez vous il y a
un an tout le monde nous donnait morts
on nous disait terrassé par le mirage
jupitérien certains apeuré alléchés par
quelques rochers quitter le navire pour
rejoindre emmanuel macron ils
trahissaient leurs convictions ils
trahissaient leurs convictions pour un
poste
certains n'ont même pas eu une malgré
leurs efforts
un an après mes amis un an après mes
amis où est la france
où en sommes nous plus d'impôts toujours
plus d'impôts plus d'injustice toujours
plus d'injustice et surtout est
peut-être encore plus plus de mépris
plus d'arrogance plus d'outrance quand
on voit mes amis investir les marches de
l'elysée maisons suprêmes de la
république par les rappeurs lors de la
fête de la musique on se dit
on se dit on a envie de dire de gaulle
reviens ils sont devenus fous
plus grave plus grave quand on voit le
rappeur médine appelant à la crucifixion
des laïcs à se produire au bataclan
on mesure la faiblesse coupable de ceux
qui nous gouvernent et leur incapacité à
nous protéger mes amis
l'illusion va faire long feu nous en
sommes certains
mais cela ne suffira pas à nous d'ouvrir
un nouveau chemin à nous d'offrir une
nouvelle espérance derrière laurent
wauquiez aujourd'hui oui grâce à laurent
wauquiez nous pouvons regarder l'avenir
avec plus d'optimisme
à condition de savoir d'où nous venons
et surtout à condition de savoir qui
nous sommes nous sommes un parti de
droite attachée à l'autorité attachés à
la liberté
nous sommes un parti de droite qui
défend la souveraineté de la france
nous sommes un parti de droite attachée
à l'identité à nos traditions à nos
racines
nous sommes nous sommes un parti de
droite qui combat l'immigration de masse
et le communautarisme terreau du
terrorisme islamiste
nous sommes un parti qui défend le
pouvoir d'achat nous sommes une famille
certes nous avons parfois des nuances
nous l'avons vu nous avons quelquefois
même des différences mais comme on
disait autrefois au rpr c'était peut
être notre temps mais on peut en nourrir
une forme de nostalgie avec c'est vrai
ces réunions qui se sont tenues ici avec
jacques chirac avec nicolas sarkozy
eh bien oui
comme on le disait autrefois notre
devoir est de chasser en meute
ce que nous faisons à l'assemblée
nationale grâce à notre formidable
présidente groupe christian jacob que je
remercie pour son engagement comme je le
fais pour mon ami bruno retailleau qui
avec la même force exerce cette mission
de cohésion de nos deux groupes
parlementaires au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale ainsi que pour tous les
parlementaires européens en saluant
frank booth
le président de la délégation française
alors oui mes amis ce qui nous réunit
est tellement plus fort que ce qui nous
sépare
alors oui rassemblons nous rassemblons
nous sans arrière pensée sans esprit de
chapelle
car c'est de la france dont il s'agit
c'est la france qui compte c'est la
france qui importe est pas les parcours
individuels les européennes
constitueront le premier grand rendez
vous électoral après nos défaites du
printemps dernier cette échéance est
naturellement essentielle et importante
je vais peut-être vous surprendre mais
moi ce qui m'importe d'abord en europe
je le dis c'est la france
nous gagnerons
nous gagnerons les élections européennes
en parlant de la france de la france de
la france de son passé de son passé
glorieux de sa culture qui a éclairé le
monde de son identité et donc de son
avenir et de son destin
le général de gaulle disait la france
vient du fond des âges
elle vit c'est notre présent l'avenir
l'appel pour autant qu'elle sache rester
elle même
alors dans ces élections parlons de la
france
oui parlons de la france d'une france en
europe et disons surtout disons très
clairement non à l'europe sans
frontières et fédérales de macron non à
l'europe fédérale et sans frontières de
monsieur macron si nous ne relevons pas
mes amis ces défis et bien l'europe
disparaîtra et la france sera engagé
dans un chemin extrêmement périlleux
pour elle nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui à un problème majeur
un défi majeur c'est celui de
l'immigration de masse
si nous ne relevons pas là aussi ce défi
il y aura plus d'europe et il n'y aura
plus de france en 2050 l'afrique
comptera 2 milliard et demi d'habitants
c'est le double de la population
actuelle l'année dernière ici à menton
cinquante mille migrants ont été
interpellés en franchissant la frontière
franco italienne
la méditerranée est devenue un cimetière
tragique avec plus de 15000 morts depuis
les demandes d'asile mes amis alors
qu'on nous dit que la crise migratoire
n'est que politique ont encore augmenté
de 15% au cours des cinq premiers mois
de l'année 2018 en france 47 1775
demande
on ne peut plus continuer comme cela on
ne peut plus continuer dans cette voie
de soumission à une immigration de masse
alors que 400 mille étrangers semaine
tiennent déjà illégalement sur le
territoire national alors oui face à
l'angélisme face aux insultes de macron
les lépreux et autres qu'ils méprisent
alors oui nous avons le devoir d'écouter
et d'être courageux je le dis tout
simplement parce que là est l'enjeu et
laurent a eu le courage d'aborder avec
force cette thématique
oui avec notre famille politique je veux
et nous voulons que la france reste la
france
l'europe l'europe est aujourd'hui
menacée d'éclatement et de divisions la
réalité de l'europe ce ne sont pas les
technocrates
ce sont des états ce sont des nations ce
sont des nations charnelle et surtout
bruno retailleau l'a dit ce sont des
peuples est une civilisation les nations
telles que l'histoire nous les allégués
reste le cadre indispensable de dollars
action future
une action indispensable pour
l'épanouissement des peuples pour
l'exercice de leur souveraineté pour la
plénitude de leur liberté et pour
l'expression de leur solidarité
ici depuis menton nous devons retrouver
l'esprit visionnaire pour cette nouvelle
robe totalement refondée mais nous
devons aussi conserver l'esprit de
résistance qui anime et charles pasqua
auquel nous avons rendu hommage hier où
philippe seguin mes amis choisir les
républicains aujourd'hui c'est refuser
l'effacement de la france
choisir les républicains c'est offrir à
notre beau et grand pays de retrouver la
maîtrise de son destin
la droite avec le centre n'ont jamais
été aussi forts que lorsqu'ils ont été
rassemblés à l'ensemble battons-nous
pour la défense des valeurs de notre
pays de son mode de vie de sa culture de
son histoire de son identité
ensemble avec laurent wauquiez pourtant
cette espérance française qui tant que
nous serons debout ne s'éteindra jamais
[Applaudissements]